if you are a clinician and you would
like CA me from this activity the person
to contact is Lynn SCH SCH wabe L at
ohsu dot edu and she will set you up
today's presentation is going to be
about lessons learned from the AMIA
meeting and the presenters our annex is
Napoli Grady right and in ho Kim who are
a cdma fellows in clinical informatics
and Aaron Hickman is the NLM fellow at
clinical informatics and so without
further ado so hello Gus thanks for
coming I'm ready right and so to start
we're going to give about a 10-minute
presentation each on what we all learned
and then we'd like you to send questions
for the end so I'll just get started
disclaimer nobody had any commercial
interest in any of these presentation so
one of the things I learned is Chicago
it was not my first trip but my first
real stay there has the worst uber cab
drivers I've ever seen it's kind of
expensive but it is a really beautiful
city highly recommend going back so the
way i took the a mia conference was I
wanted to explore I'm relatively new in
informatics so I really wanted to see
what's out there so I focused on going
to demos rather than more advanced
research one of the more interesting
demos I guess organizations that gave
multiple demos with the National Library
of Medicine which you are familiar with
clin McDonald's amazing person more
energy than I'll probably ever have that
he went over at least three things that
I'll talk about one was our x norm which
is a drug database the other one is
clinical table search service and then
all kind of ties together with their LHC
forms the RX norm is like I said it's a
web well it's a database of the
collection of databases of a lot of drug
information
really useful the primary way to access
it is there are ex nav website it's a
web-based browser it can display
everything from drugs dosages
formulations as both generic and
brand-name lookups you just simply type
in the search box at the bottom and you
can get a lot of good information right
there on the homepage it can also do
some more advanced things like map
relationships from for example mesh
tables like here on the right I have met
results Matt to mesh terms it's a proton
pump inhibitor you can manipulate that
map actually right there on the website
and it can do also like to Xia logic
mechanisms of action and and it's a
really really neat service has the
service that can do he'll images and you
have to give it a specific dosage type
to get the pill images that and then
lastly you can do drug interactions and
whistles for you and you're able to get
that straight from some of the database
the really cool thing about the new RX
norm is that it has an API so a program
interface and it's built on this restful
application so you can just do it
straight in HTTP and there is there's
the prescriber one which filters out
only and it focuses on the US for
survivable information there's our X
terms it's linked to the VA's in DF
database which has most of the
interactions in it and then it actually
has the RX of image API so the cool
thing about that is you can use it in
your own applications you don't have to
start from scratch and build your own
drug database or buy some expensive drug
database you can rely on them to provide
the underlying database for a really
robust clinical application this is just
an example of one of the coolest things
I saw the spelling suggestions for drug
names so if you typed in on prazzer soul
which is something patients like the
kool omeprazole for some reason then it
will actually return suggestions for
similar matching names
then the next thing that that they
talked about is clinical table search
service this is a back end and it's
another API and it enables you to easily
query other databases such as icd-10
codes are X terms dragon ingredients
these long forms of genes allele sniffs
I think there's 10 or 12 databases total
you can really quickly you can see with
that small amount of code come up with a
a box or something that you can type in
jet engine for whatever reason sucked
into jet engines subsequent encounter so
you can build that very very quickly and
again use what they've done they've done
all the legwork and they maintain these
databases for you and then I tie it all
together with what they've created is
called LHC forms and it's a widget
toolkit so you can build widgets and it
uses the clinical tool search service
and when it forms and it's written
entirely in JavaScript and angularjs
framework so you can build widgets that
do clinical entry basically and the
underlying mechanisms are like you've
seen already built like here's an
example of the phq-9 the panel which is
really quick to build so another
interesting talk I went to was from the
VA they always like to show off their
new tech and they're really their newest
and coolest tech that I've seen was the
their new next-generation EHR which is
called the electronic health management
platform or eh and Peter sorta Johnson
never could show this off what this
specific demo was about was the novel
features for what they call activity
management and notifications basically a
task manager but it was pretty cool so
the EMP is is still under pretty heavy
development they just came out with
version 2 point 0 which is enabled the
right functions so they can actually
write back to the database again it's
built partially using JSON and also use
aspire interfaces and it's essentially
completely widget
so that's kind of why I wanted to add
this in here on top of the other things
it could be a platform for building
widgets that that we could build and
apply and use this platform being built
on fire interfaces with JSON it could
all work together specifically their
activity management service was pretty
cool because they designed it in such a
way to where you can for example if you
put in a consult for pulmonology then
that consult will be tasked to go to
some pulmonologist you don't have to
specify what pulmonologists or where it
just goes to that specific Colin ologist
or if you want to ask the primary care
to follow up on a lab you bored in the
hospital you just have to say follow
primary care then the system actually
manages that in the back end and will
either into two primary care or if that
fails that will send it back to you it's
a pretty robust system that they've
implemented and are trying to pull at
the VA so our up so i'll spit not common
when I hand it off to dr. chin upon me
what I learned at Amy a couple things
and first off I learned that one of the
best work things about aim is there's so
much there that often times all the
things you want to see happen is exactly
the same time so you can never really
see everything I also learned get a
hotel at a mia because my parents lived
there so I had to drive every day which
was a nice hour drive back and forth but
I was fun but what I wanted to get out
of a male was really to look at the
things that I'm interested in the things
that affect me and then also kind of go
beyond my own scope and kind of learn
about things that I may not know much
about or may not be as knowledgeable
about but I certainly seemed interesting
and things that I think are important so
there are three things that i learned
that i'm going to share with everybody
today the first one it kind of relates
to personal interest in mind which is
being a clinician being someone who
interacted with the hrs very much on the
front at level usability of something
that has a you know i'd certainly have a
great deal of interest in and so one of
the presentations that i went to that I
found pretty interesting for several
reasons
namely that the presentation was focused
on usability but actually a lot of the
questions are directed at the
application itself and it was a
usability of an automated reminder
system for clinical order entry so the
way the presentation worked it was that
it was focused on a usability of the
CPOE clinical decision support system
that would offer providers a
recommendation of orders based on the
diagnosis code now how that
recommendation would be done Wood was
that it would function similar to the
Amazon product algorithm of customers
who bought this product also bought this
feature by showing orders that providers
entered other providers entered for the
exact same diagnosis and it showed it
based on their frequency so for example
if you entered an order of sepsis and
you were treating someone with an icd-9
code of sepsis it would out it would
look at all the other providers who was
true was treating someone for sepsis and
look at all the different orders that
they had put in labs medications and
then it would display that information
to you in a clinical decision support
system and show you what the other
providers had entered and that was kind
of the the system that they were showing
off now mainly the topics the the talks
focused a lot of it on the usability of
it but I thought it was interesting also
kind of and why it was being designed
because this CD s kind of stood in
contrast to human authored order sets
which is what we do now we typically
have a small group of people designing
these order sets based on the guidelines
of based on guidelines and based on
recommendations and this is trying
another approach at it and and
determining its validity and they did a
study that said that it is as effective
and i apologize i don't have the the the
paper with me and like i said he was
trying to focus mainly on usability but
can really get there because i think
people were more interested in that so
some of the things from a usability
standpoint that i found that was
interesting is that physicians typically
don't think in terms of numbers of what
people order the most so when they say
ppv that positive predictive value
that's showing how many other physicians
ordered the exact same thing so if you
had a ppv of 99% of sepsis or if it was
sepsis and say a antibiotico such as
like vancomycin
that would be 99 percent meaning that
99% of physicians would order this
medication if they were treating someone
for sepsis so that's kind of how it was
but positions when they were interacting
with the system they didn't like this
and to show it in numbers they typically
think in terms of groupings meds the
labs order things like that and so that
was things that they had to rearrange
and also showing things like PPV
relative risk and these kind of
different variables was too much
information which is another kind of
common usability seen that we think
about don't show people more information
than they need only show them what's
relevant to their to them at the time
that they need it so these are all kind
of usability lessons that I took away
from it to kind of in the future if I
ever want to kind of work on usability
projects and usability studies things to
think about so I took this from Amyas
booklet they had a PDF that kind of
showed off a lot of their head summaries
an abstract for their papers and he
managed to show an image I know it's
very blurry I do apologize for that but
basically on the left side this was a
kind of a homegrown system that he
showed and this was the HMP at the top
where you showed the orders and based on
that this was a clinical decision
support system that was was displayed to
the user and again like I said kind of
showing the different levels of
percentages of how people did it and
this was after the redesign where he
kind of categorized them into the labs
meds and microbiology tastes like that
the second one is one that I think has
affected me as a clinician and something
that I deal with a lot and you know
we've talked about this which is problem
lists and how we maintain problem lists
and has been a great deal of issue for
clinicians because personally I know
that we don't maintain it that well
oftentimes you'll see a lot of patients
with multiple problems better the exact
same thing being written multiple times
you see problem with their not being
updated and so that certainly creates a
problem for physicians because it
creates a system that's not exactly very
usable and so one of the other demos
that I saw that I thought was quite
interesting with intelligent medical
objects and they were a company that's
trying to come up with a solution
their core function was to simplify the
coding process and bridge that gap
between coding systems and medical
terminology so what they would do is
they would take multiple lists or
multiple problem list and icd-9 and
icd-10 codes and they would try to group
them together into more clinically
relevant groupings so instead of having
CHF systolic heart failure diastolic
heart failure and having five different
things at the same time they would take
that into one category of cardiovascular
disease and group that together and two
and into heart failure with you know
whatever grouping that they would list
to basically take those kind of
convoluted ICD 9 and 10 codes and group
them into more clinically relevant
terminology that physicians can use and
and has more value for the physicians so
I think that was interesting to me
because I think it works to kind of
serve that gap and bridge that gap at
this point dr. Kim is going to kind of
you know talk a little bit more about
prom list and some of the other talks
that we went to that kind of address
problem list as well and he has some
other topics there so I'm not going to
go too much but this was I think
interesting in terms of visualization of
that data and how we group it together
and how we present it to the physician
and then the last one is one that I
think was very much a hot topic at at a
meal which was fire and then smart on
fire and using that and then one of the
topics that I went to that I thought was
pretty interesting was how do we present
that information how do we get the app
to the clinician at the point of care
because as the system as it as it
currently exists in the system right now
for a smart app if you want to run a
smart app on epic using the fire
standard you would have to run that app
simultaneously with the EHR at the same
time and that can be very cumbersome
because if you have five different smart
apps that you want to run you would have
to run all five at the same time or run
them when you need them and you'd have
to know when to when you would need them
and that can be very cumbersome and can
make it very difficult to use so one of
the things for the group that is
designed to smart apps that they want to
kind of put in place so that these apps
can be run automatically at the point of
care was something called a CD s hook
and a PDF hook assembly is simply a
system where the EHR vendor would allow
for a call to an app to be triggered
based on a specific user action or a
trigger point so if you try and enter a
specific order or specific
eddore you reach a certain point in your
workflow that would trigger certain
smart app to be use and I think that's
very important I think that's very
useful useful as we talk about smart and
fire and all these different apps that
come out I think one of the important
things is to make sure that these apps
become triggered at the point of care
rather than expecting physicians to know
all the apps that exist out there it can
pull those abs and call the apps that we
need at the time that we need it so I
found that that topic tur that
presentation was very interesting with
that I will turn it over to dr. ken time
inhale so starting to talk about his
problem lists and workflow there's two
majority of the two topics that I found
interesting and so part of the reason my
problem lists were a lot of the talks at
amas that there is no standard single
standard definition one of the kind of
general definitions that people have
it's it's a list used within health
records usually with illnesses injuries
other factors that can affect the health
of an individual patient you know
there's multiple definitions by for
meaningful use stage 1 Joint Commission
hl7 and just to give you kind of an idea
of how different those definitions are
meaningful uses stage 1 definitions
maintain an up-to-date problem list of
current and active diagnoses based on
icd-9 or sno-med for eighty percent of
patients ad spend the time and has to
have at least one coded problem as
opposed the entire problem is coded
Joint Commission's definition is any
significant medical diagnosis and
conditions any significant operative
invasive procedures adverse allergic
drug reactions any current medications
over counter medications in herbal
preparations and hl7 has even slightly
different one it may include but not
limited to chronic conditions diagnosis
symptoms functional limitations again
that's slightly different from the other
two definitions visit state specific
conditions diagnosis or symptoms and so
as you can see no single standard and
can vary even between different national
kind of definitions that we have and so
with that
one of the groups IBM Watson tried to
hit have a way to better curate the
problem list that's relevant to
clinicians because much of a time
problem is aghani would say is like at
CHS to solid failure diet Oxford's like
overrun with sometimes duplicate
problems or problems that aren't
relevant to the clinician or provider
and so they tried to set up kind of a
test for Watson to see if Watson could
supplement clinician use curation and
thinking in regards to the problem lists
using some MLP some knowledge base
features some clinical attributes and to
eventually create models in Watson for
what is and what is not a problem and so
how they kind of tested this the gold
standard was the physician and the
physician to physicians would review the
charts and then go over to find to
curate what they believed to be the
actual problem list and then they were
give it was given a rating for how close
it was to what actually should be on the
problem list and so as you can see from
the x-axis that's the rating on the
bottom of how high the rating so further
to the right is better rating and then
the y-axis is account so the pink on top
from this their study was just how the
problem is curated now the physicians
went through the problem list before
using Watson ordering the two physician
review and saw you know how clinically
relevant is the problem list you know
there a lot of duplications or not a lot
of duplication and they gave it a rating
and you can see from the like I guess
standard of care before checking with
physicians or before checking with
Watson the ratings are kind of all over
the place and there's like lower counts
I mean lower rating counts you know down
below the green is a physician gold
standard and that's very much the right
a little bit selling prophecy because
they're reviewing their own charts and
then the blue is Watson and and
basically they're kind of criteria with
how close is Watson to the green like
how close is the blue to the green
and it's pretty good my van Watson jury
was saying like you know it's Watson did
a pretty good job with the parsing and
the and the vectors and they're kind of
algorithms they used and then so some
kind of during the discussion the panel
something that came up were that some
physicians in the in the audience were
worried that the Watson group was trying
to supplant provider thinking and the
same person kept arguing about that and
then but they kind of tried to I guess
alleviate that by saying that this is
really just to catch things that may be
positioned didn't catch and they
acknowledged that Watson did catch a
couple of items that should have been on
the problem with that weren't on the
physician providers problem list and
even after the physician spent an hour
on average decision spend an hour on the
chart so after an hour there were still
a couple of problems that the physicians
misdiagnosis or clinical symptoms that
the physicians miss that Watson picked
up and so at the end of the day the Iban
group was trying to say yes like we
don't want to supplant physicians but we
want them to have another kind of
resource that can use to help curate the
problem list to maybe catch things as
they might have missed so another
problem list kind of talk I went to it
was really quick like five minutes kind
of rapid session talk was from dr.
Bannon at Cleveland Clinic and his idea
was more kind of a social kind of issue
where we have to have a better way of
managing problem less and to start by
doing that we should teach our medical
students better and how to do this was
to make sure that anything that's on the
problem list has a plan that if it
doesn't have a plan it shouldn't be on
the problem list and it should be taken
off and a easy example is if you're
admitted for lobar pneumonia and you
finish your antibiotic treatment you
should take lobar pneumonia off your
problem list because if you've completed
antibiotics you are no longer have lobar
pneumonia whereas if you have chronic
knee pain and you still require rehab it
should still be on there and even made a
point to say if you have pre-diabetes
you're not on a medication you maybe
don't even have follow-up but your diet
may be slightly different and so even in
that sense pre-diabetes can be on your
problem list because it has a plan of a
diet and so in that way to try to be all
inclusive but not have every single
little issue beyond the problem with and
now some other kind of different talks I
went to so this one kind of talk I went
to was on workflow and it was about
trying to standardize workflows and
capture that in a standardized fashion
so you can know what you're doing and
then to see if there's any changes after
implementation and this was done at
Arizona State University which is a Mayo
Center and they were doing a new epoch
immed implementation and so they were
trying to find a way to capture clinical
workflows and again a standardized
fashion so we had this like kind of
chart to basically kind of ask and
answer questions of who does what like
crazy activities when where and how
basically some sub activities if you can
think of like imploring which resources
or tools and kind of each blue kind of
boxes those questions of who why what
and the the orange is kind of those
activities and more details of those and
so they were then take this and have
those relevant concepts and try to make
activity network diagrams and and again
again into all of this it's not
necessarily always just formal work
structures but also they will combine
informal and formal work structures to
kind of pull this all together and to
have a uncomplete cohesive kind of
diagram of the fit of the work flow in a
standardized / again so as a sample case
they had that like for those delayed
surgeries and so you have these long
cases and you're trying to make sure
that surgeries aren't delayed because of
like our nurses having taking too long
to do Medicus medication reconciliation
and so some of the things that they need
to find for the analysts to create a
standard workflow image or picture with
patient and provider centric tivity
diagrams task durations information
needs and
and sources of variation and so this is
kind of an example of what they would
try to diagram on a bigger level the
blue boxes you can figure them as
activities and each of those blue
hexagons can be further split up into
multiple steps of sub activities and so
they would just continue to break it
down until they had every sub activity
and activity kind of flushed out in a
standardized fashion using those
questions from the previous blue and
orange diagram you saw before and that
would be four RN for crnas and you see a
urologist etc and so with the workflow
like this is kind of an example of how
they would fill that chart out in a
standardized method and again this is
just a sub activity of like Medicus of
the Medicus medication reconciliation
and you can see there's just like either
RN with the patient and to whom is like
surgery patient just filling out every
little box to make sure they have it all
filled out and then eventually they take
those sub activities activities filled
out and then this is how they would kind
of capture all that information and so
you can see that do ethnography and
observation using more a video to
capture anything so they it just in case
they missed it during just watching in
person they would also take artifacts
and an artifact being those charts and
filling out those charts and those
diagrams and then finally just in case
have another level of kind of detail to
make sure some of my standardized
captured a workflow they would take time
like the timestamp blogs to try to have
another layer to make sure they're
having a standardized way they're
capturing the workflow thank you so I'm
going to hopefully finish this and won't
keep you guys too long so I went to some
sessions on patient portals one of them
was part of the sea mio like workshop
but then one of them which is like a
standalone session so these are some
things that I learned for most I'm so
just starting out some of the meaningful
use goals for patient care so our
students for patient portals so one the
first measure is that
more than fifty percent of unique piece
patients seen by eligible professionals
during the EHR reporting period are
provided timely access to like view
online download and transmit I'm the
second 14 2015 2016 is at least one
patient seen by an eligible professional
during the EHR reporting period is able
to view or download but for 2017 they're
looking for more than five percent of
those unique patients it was slowly
starting to build up and have more
importance in regards to meaningful use
and so somebody had done a study
regarding like predictors of use with
the patient portal so they found that
people with like disabilities and
chronic diseases were more likely to use
them I'm healthcare frequent flyers and
then caregivers of like the elderly or
kids were more likely to use them
negative predictors were minorities
people over 35 healthy and then on the
left educated and then on the right side
so when you see this dark blue this was
a study done out of Southern California
and somebody had looked at their five
community hospitals with 13,000 to
60,000 patients others 13 clinics with
the myths and basically what they were
trying to see was get a feel for their
like health care system for on patient
portals and so when they looked at their
system the things they found regarding
why patients weren't using them as
frequently we're pretty much similar to
this other study I'm done somewhere also
language was a big one on literacy fear
deportation so this is like seems like
an underserved community and then
digital literacy so what patients say
they use patient Porter's for so when
asked have you ever used to patient
portals I'm seven percent of all adults
said so and then what was most useful
about the patient portal what they said
was making sure the information was
correct I'm and so in terms of what the
sea mio and like what kind of dry
patient portals the thought is like
there's going to be better medication
adherence better management of the
disease self-management appointment
adherence but some reasons why people
aren't like tuned in the patient pearls
so again we saw some of eliminating
reasons on the last slide so non-english
speakers pediatric so one of the cmas
was said once the child turns 13 in
their system then they give like access
to the child so you can imagine if you
have this like 14 or 15 year old who
like secretive about the stuff maybe mom
doesn't know what's going on we should
go into the appointments and then the
issue of privacy and then there's this
other thing kind of related to patient
portals Vanessa patient generates
healthcare data I'm so how they defined
it was really health related data
including health history symptoms
biometric data treatment history
lifestyles better like essentially
gathered or inferred from the patient
and one of the talks I had went to they
had like categorize it at the different
categories so one was provider generated
patient monitored so this was what they
deemed is like information that our data
volunteered by the patients and then
purposely collected data on this is like
your smart technology smart watches and
then volunteered patient advice so this
was how patients interpreted their data
so maybe they didn't bring their
SmartWatch to the appointment but they
were like oh I hit like 75 percent of my
like Apple watch milestones whatever
that means and then data collected the
third party so it was like Twitter
whatever secret really monitoring every
time we searched something and then
you're using that without her consent
and then so this chart so that they
asked like physicians in US and across
like the globe what they thought
patients should be able to use the
portal for and I'm not sure you can we
read on the first I'm not sure you can
read it but essentially the green is
like all information like what they
believe the patient should be able to do
and the US physicians are on the right
and then on the left column is global
so the biggest green area is on the
bottom so demographic information so
basically physicians say like we don't
mind if the patient's like putting in
demographics but as you get further up
to the top is lab tests out results so
maybe you had your test results at
hospital a like they don't care that
they don't want you to bring it toss
little B and like put it in the computer
socially um so other concerns with these
different models so like it's this
position it's like hiding notes so like
maybe you do like a psych eval or
something and you like hide the note
then like it did something it's like
disservice to the patient patients are
like really allowed to like generate
notes or their own notes and then with
some of the purpose we collected data
selective smartwatches is it like a
lifestyle again like I hit all my Apple
milestone sources like it's as I walked
three miles accuracies if I like bring
my arm a hundred times you know did I
walk an extra milder day and how does
that get logged and then the legal
implementation is kind of what drove
like my interest in this patient portal
thing so there was a TMI o from a
pediatric center who basically said that
they were starting to use their portal
for secure messaging and so they were
going to allow time during the day like
block out certain like an hour in the
morning in the afternoon for these
outpatient providers to be able to
message with their patient and so the
guidelines was there were the providers
would have to return the messages within
24 hours I'm patients could send data
for example like blood glucose values
and then the provider could like sign
off on it and it would generate a PDF
which would then be put into the chart
so this like drove a lot of interest I
was like oh that's like one like
workflow so that night I actually had
dinner with two of my like former co
residents and some of the things that we
had come up with during our conversation
was one they were like thank goodness I
didn't do outpatient it's now I'm going
to have to respond to text messages
added work like influences on workflow
liability it's like a patient under F
first overestimate their symptoms I'm
just like are they using it for
emergency situations so let's say if
somebody sent something on like the
first hour and you don't see it until
the 23rd and they should be in the
hospital because they have like a really
high glucose or something and then going
back to the study that I showed you from
California so essentially they created
like a patient portal in the hospital
and so when they talk to staff I thought
some of these quotes are interesting so
they said we stopped other words to get
our enrollment numbers baito staff tried
to enroll at every opportunity we we had
to set them up with email if there was
time we would teach them how to navigate
their inbox so like the thought is like
you generate this patient portal and
then you have like more communication
with the patient but like I think a lot
of what's like forgotten is the work and
the one that was really sad is this one
it says we really didn't want all our
patients signed up we just need to reach
the five percent requirement so
essentially while the goal of these like
patient portals is to make make the
patient feel empowered I think there's
some hesitation from physicians and
maybe even some patients about like its
youth so some of the conclusions were in
recommendations were similar to what I
had come up with so basically not just
focusing on meeting the five percent or
like the meaningful use requirements but
being able to build a system that is
like usable and appealing to all
patients how to do that I'm not sure
because there's such a discrepancy right
now who uses it who doesn't but in
talking yesterday when i was giving the
practice on one thing in hope had
brought up is maybe having some more
like clinical decision support feature
or some sort of kick back to the patient
so that they want to use it and maybe
where it takes some of the burden off
the physician so that is the end of our
presentation if you guys have any
questions for anybody we're ready to go
so I actually meant to ask I'm curious
how many people here actually went to
Amy ok cool sunland so yeah comments
questions arguments criticism
I think so I'm in a lot of wood they
talked about and I felt I kind of felt
bad because I think he was trying to
really get at the usability and he had a
study and i'll be happy to life sending
him on a link for for where it was i
know i have it somewhere but i think
it's a concern because you know is it
and i think even he said is it wisdom of
the crowd or the mentality of the mob
and it's if everyone does something does
that mean it's still the right thing to
do I think that was one of the first
questions that people brought up and he
all he spent probably ninety percent of
his talk defending what he was designing
not defending the usability expect
design but i think you know as we just
had that one talk just recently about
even about the kind of medicine that we
do changes a lot even the guidelines
that we follow so how often are our
order sets updated and maintained and
that was kind of his you know argument
is that again if all the physicians are
following in theory the best practice of
the best guidelines is this an equally
valid way of presenting the decision
support to the user for what should be
ordered for a particular diagnosis if
you follow one you know the way we do
order sets now it's very small group of
people that design and based on whatever
the clinical guidelines are and this is
kind of taking that other approach to it
you know I I think I had a feeling
everyone's like questions would be
focused more on the validity of that
madness and its general outcome and I
think that's to be honest I would have
to look kind of more into it and to say
whether or not that's equally valid or
leads to the same outcomes as following
a human authored order set that follows
best practice and so you're right and I
don't know which is right now I have to
kind of look at it to say which is more
valid so you know it's a great question
and you know unfortunately I can't give
you the best answer for that yes
oh it wasn't it was it was it was their
first it's like the first step of many
steps it was the first step was like
they want to find the baseline and then
if I didn't make that clear I'm sorry it
was it was like their their part the
part of their kind of panel to support
was just to show how they were creating
a standardized method to capture
clinical workflows so that they could
then see is it better worse getting
better or worse and have a baseline to
then improve upon yeah that's what
that's why I went like I was interested
in that talk but it was it was more just
like how they captured it so that they
could maybe one day do that yeah yeah
for this one Bay like pretty much we're
trying to drive it to the provider but
they like basically they were saying
they were getting a lot of kickback so
they were going to try to figure out how
to put like the nurses in there but they
weren't sure like that's where the level
of triage would be at that point I don't
care very much but I know in the portal
that we have here there's pretty clear
language that there are certain things
you shouldn't be asking urgent questions
you're not tired propria for that so did
they say anything about the design of
the portals to the effect of you know
kind of educating people about what's
appropriate to
yeah like so that was like one of the
big conversation points in that meeting
and she liked people other see at my
older like you know in our hospital
we're a little concerned about doing
this for those reasons and she was like
you know we're trying to like educate
the patient when they sign up like what
to message on and then they were
actually trying to take some of the
burden off positions by having like
smart phrases so that they could like
put smart like if somebody had a caustic
it like smart fries cough it seemed a
little to me like it all seemed a little
bit dangerous I'm like so like regality
of different stuff but they were she was
confident that they were going to have
success with the system kind of on that
point I don't know if people saw there
were some posters on kind of patient
generated data but I don't know if it
was the necessary data someone had
prototypes of what apps might look like
if you had one was for diabetes I no one
was for HIV patients for either side
effects are having or symptoms that
they're having they would have cards of
they were showing patience like what
they're feeling or how they're feeling
and then if they felt that then the
prototype the app would generate what
they should what the patient should be
doing so it's kind of like it's a kind
of like patient portable instead of
using the portal is like self-management
giving the HIV patient better self
management tool to say I'm not feeling
good and then being like that could be
for side effects from this medication
you're taking and you should you know
eat more of whatever or do this or
exercise and to kind of have like
another layer of icon not a layer but
like a self-management for the patient
there was some really interesting poster
on that
and I'm sorry and I would take it even a
step further to say that when we take
the patient history we're attributing
our own biases in that story itself and
if you know the patient can give the
exact same story but the five different
physicians might write it down five
different ways based on their own
impressions based on their own stories
and so I think you know I've kind of
been doing a little bit of research into
into P hrs and one of the things that
has more validity tends to be that
subjective nature of people entering
their symptoms and describing those
things and even certain objective things
like their weight their blood pressure
could you know could be entered with
some validity and so yeah kind of going
on anything else okay thank you
[Applause]